this is no one lights up like mr. Martin
Short you come out there and that light
hits you well I mean it's awfully
appreciated yeah and I didn't even know
there was an audience I'd heard the
monologue but you know it was kind of a
deep space quiet you look sensational oh
really I do I know you do I'm telling
you the new queer I cast is doing
wonders with I haven't even talked to
them that's not because I mean see I
think there's nothing wrong with looking
pasty is it I mean I think no I mean
you're pale yes
Europe hey you you have no white man
make Mike pinch look like a character in
Black Panther there's no you need to
brace yourself more than what comes
after a Martin no no I mean he put
sunscreen on at night hippest tabby cat
suit in a Duraflame log listen listen
listen I Barbra Streisand would clone
yous
the theory that heavy drinking ages of
men thank you thank you thank you so
much Marty I love it when you're on for
a period of time and then you're glad
that I'm gone and then I'm so glad
you're gone I think I have probably all
this coming I really no you don't you
don't you know that we are very very
we're good for close friends you are in
that kind of fictiony this thing
you